it's been a while since I had a clip for
you of just good old-fashioned religious
nutter II that's indistinguishable from
mental illness and I've sort of been
getting away from these sorts of clips
unless they're linked to something in
the news because I think most of the
audience at this point has a pretty good
understanding and sense of this
completely unhinged religious zealotry
but today we actually have an example of
religious nutter II that's directly
linked to the news and specifically
Hurricane Dorian hurricane Dorian is a
real thing people have died untold
damage is being done President Trump
sending confusing messages about it
saying it's going to hit Alabama but it
isn't and there are people refusing to
evacuate this is this is real it's as
real as real gets there are people who
are losing their lives and at risk of
losing their lives because of this storm
and in the midst of all this in comes a
grifter named Kat Kerr who shows up and
records herself commanding the hurricane
with a stick in the name of Jesus and
some kind of bizarre prayer I don't even
know what to call it my question is can
we call this anything other than mental
illness is there any other
categorization for what I'm about to
show you let's look at it together so
right now at this moment we take
authority over Dorian it has no right
off the coast of this state or anywhere
and we hit that storm to the east right
now and I'm gonna do it three times we
hit it to the east we headed to the east
and command you go to these aren't away
from land we declare you would do no
destruction in any way we won't tolerate
it so father I thank you for this honor
a privilege to be here on the literal
coast of Florida and we say to that
store your end is coming
we don't tolerate your presence we won't
tolerate you coming ashore anywhere or
causing any harm death or destruction we
speak on behalf of those who have
already been abducted by God we thank
you for a rapid recovery and restoration
for all of them right now we decree and
declare you Dorian your days and hours
are numbered and we bash you she tells
the storm that its end is coming well
yeah I mean storms end eventually that's
not much
that's not very prosaic I must say do we
just need to call this what it is
mental illness how else would we
describe something like this this is
like a crazy person yelling at a cloud I
mean did this is no different and if you
look more into I've never heard of this
person before but so many people emailed
me that I said I've got to figure out
more about her she has a website called
the revelation zone it has a whole bunch
of stuff on it including videos
frequently asked questions about
eternity some of the stuff seems
straight-up satirical but I don't I
don't think it is like I I wonder is it
possible this is all a joke because no
other explanation would suffice
check out some of the questions she
answers from kids on her website
fourteen-year-old Emily from
Jacksonville Florida wrote are there
oceans with sharks and jellyfish in
heaven and Catco wrote yes there is a
crystal sea which comes from the river
of life that flows out of God's throne
oh yeah of course also the Bible states
that there are fish of all kinds in the
water and the crystal sea is big enough
to hold huge sailing ships another
question from Trey who is age six from
Richmond Virginia question is letting
Trey write to this woman a form of child
abuse I think that's something we should
consider
six-year-old Trey asks is there an art
easel and a t-rex in heaven Kat Kerr
says yes to both questions since I saw
art galleries there I don't know if she
means she was in heaven at one point I
am certain they would have easels to
paint on also there are representations
of an all of all animal life that God
originally created so deines
including the t-rex can be seen in the
park area of heaven ah the park area of
course they are so tamed that you can
actually ride on them that's right there
are tamed t-rexes living in the park
area of heaven next to the easels which
must exist because cat kur knows that
there are art galleries in heaven and if
there are art galleries there must be
easels with which the art is made this
is dangerous this is dangerous
children should not be exposed to this
woman we've previously discussed on the
program its we haven't done this for a
while and I'm now getting myself fired
up and talking about it we've previously
discussed on the program is it a form of
child abuse to place the irrational fear
of going to hell in the minds of
children from a young age it is other
forms of causing a rational fear or
persistent fear in children can be
considered child abuse is the fear of
head of hell rather consider child abuse
in some way shape or form that's
something we've discussed this is crazy
to let wit of children interact with
this woman and this might not come as a
huge shock to you this woman is a big
trump estai was looking through her
Twitter account yesterday she has tweets
about Trump 2020 events and just how
great the National Day of Prayer is and
this type of thing is that surprising to
you did anybody think from the video of
her trying to hit the hurricane with a
stake in the name of Jesus that she
might have been a Bernie supporter I
don't know that that many people were
confused about that but in case you were
this is a major Trump supporter really
wacky stuff and I guess what she did
didn't work because the storm still hit
but the way that these folks work if you
were to confront her she would say well
no no no I did move the hurricane my
prayer would the stick made it so that
even more people weren't killed by
Hurricane durian which is of course
exactly the type of unfalsifiable belief
that doesn't really pass muster if you
apply even an iota of critical thinking
this is not a joke this stuff ruins
people's lives it completely takes over
their worldview and is sort of unrelated
but related story of religious nutter II
we
recently found out that one of the main
pushers or advocates of so-called
conversion therapy where people can get
therapy to stop being gay is a gay man
and I know it didn't come as a shock to
me I'm guessing it doesn't come as a
shock to many people in our audience but
this stuff is not just oh these are just
their beliefs and everyone's entitled to
their beliefs and ahh bla bla bla
okay they're entitled to their beliefs
but they're using those beliefs in a
weaponized form to ruin the lives of gay
and lesbian people to ruin the lives of
children with irrational fears and and
beliefs that are not based in reality
this actually has a real-world impact
and it also has the impact by the way if
you're really religious and you think
something like this works you might
choose not to evacuate for the hurricane
because you think Kat Kerr is gonna use
her stick and get the hurricane out of
the way then you get killed by the
hurricane this stuff has a real-world
impact and we cannot write it off as
just benign spirituality because it's
simply not that